et nous commençons donc cette édition du
78 en ce 16 mai par de la politique hier
soir David Douillet était à Mani lesamot
à l'invitation d'Aurore berger candidate
investi par l'UMP pour les prochaines
municipal le député de la 12e
circonscription des ivelines est venu
parler des élections bien sûr tout en
précisant qu'il ne serait pas candidat
dans son qu'une commune malgré les
différentes rumeurs l'annonçant d'abord
du côté de poissie en tant que tête de
liste mais aussi à rouan il est aussi
revenu David Douillet sur son soutien à
Henry guenud dont les propos à
l'encontre du juge Gentil font l'objet
d'une enquête l'ancien ministre des
Sport a signé avec d'rre députés UMP en
début de semaine une lettre ouverte ils
reprennent à leur compte les propos du
député de la 3e circonscription
seulement Valérie pcrè une autre député
chef de fil dans le département du
mouvement de l'UMP n'a pas souhaité y
prendre part je vous propose de
l'écouter écouter sa réaction à ce sujet
chacun est libre je voilà bon pas de
mais ils se sont vu avec Henry ils en
ont parlé ensemble je crois qu'elle
voulait faire elle voulait avoir une
initiative individuelle propre faut lui
poser la question moi je suis heureux de
vivre dans une démocratie j'ai eu cette
chance de voir ce qu'était une
dictature j'ai depuis l'âge de 16 ans
dans mes dans ma première vie voyager
dans beaucoup de pays j'ai eu cette
chance et j'ai vu ce qui'est ce qui
était antisme et cetera dans une dans un
pays être dans notre pays et pouvoir
dire ce que l'on veut de quiconque et en
particulier de n'importe quel casque peu
importe laquelle c'est une vraie liberté
et et surtout pour un parlementaire
c'est ça mon soutien derrière Henri
parce que on a le droit de dire à
quelqu'un que on estime qu'il a pas bien
fait les choses voilà c'est c'est c'est
notre
liberté vous le savez également si vous
nous suiviez hier pour le 7 Marine Le
Pen est venu à Versailles rencontrer des
militants mais soutenir également les
candidats investis les premiers
candidats investis par son parti le
parti frontiste pour les prochaines
municipales l'occasion pour la
présidente du Front national de préciser
qu'il n'est pas question d'accord au
niveau national avec l'UMP mais
néanmoins des rapprochements locaux sont
possibles reportage Catherine zulato
Sophie valal également Marine Le Pen
poursuit son tour de France des
fédérations départementales une halte ce
mercredi soir à Versailles pour soutenir
les candidats au municipal avec des
espoirs dans les givelines bien sûr
c'est une fédération qui a repris un
très grand dynamisme qui marche très
bien qui est une des belles fédérations
d'île-de-fance car sur fond de crise de
réforme des retraites d'se du chômage et
d'insécurité le Front National est plus
que jamais sûr de séduire les électeurs
l'ambiance a changé assure les
représentants ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que même des gens qui ont
sollicite pas même des gens qui ne sont
pas adhérents viennent nous voir et ça
franchement on doit beaucoup à parce que
elle a réussi quand même à ce que des
gens puissent comme ça venir vers nous
sans avoir peur dans leur propre commune
d'afficher leur couleurs dans les
ivelines 10 têtes de liste sont connues
et à versaill le candidat se voit déjà
au second tour je pense que le Front
national va rentrer en force au conseil
municipal de Versailles de par le fait
que les les testes qui sont les nôtres
paraissent maintenant évidentes pour
tout le monde aussi bien pour les gens
de droite que pour les gens de gauche un
Front National qui fait moins peur il y
a 3 jours en Picardie une brèche s'est
ouverte avec une alliance locale pour
les municipales entre le FN et l'UMP et
Marine Le Pen laisse la porte
entrebaillé nous ne Pons pas faire un
accord national avec l'UMP donc il y
aura peut-être des listes
d'intérêts
communal qui pourront voir sur des gens
qui viennent de l'UMP des gens du Front
national il y en aura quelquesunes c'est
possible en France le FN a déjà
rassemblé 450 candidat sur le secteur de
50 ans en Eveline Philippe Chevrier n'a
pas caché la probabilité d'une liste
frontiste à Montini le
Bretonneux et je profite de ce point
politique pour vous donner rendez-vous
ce weekend sur TVfil pour le 3e numéro
de municipal 2014 le magazine de la
rédaction magazine mensuelle il sera
question de l'engagement des jeunes lors
de la prochaine campagne de mars
première diffusion samedi à 10h émission
qui sera également à consulter sur notre
site Internet à travers le replay